i think we're now ready to get into the
meat of the proof and the last video we
said if we can just prove that each of
these parts are equal to each other
we've essentially have proven that that
is equal to that because here in yellow
is another way of writing the flux
across the surface and here in green is
another way of writing the triple
integral over our region of the
divergence of f and what i'm going to do
in this video and probably the next
video is prove that these two are
equivalent to each other i'm going to
and i'm going to prove it using the fact
that our original region is a simple
solid region in particular is a type
is a type 1 region
and then that's essentially going to be
it because you can use the exact same
argument and the fact that it is a type
2 region to prove this
type 2 region the exact same argument to
prove this and the exact same argument
and the fact that it is a type 3 region
type 3 region to prove that so i'm going
to assume it's a type one which i can
it's a type one and two it's a type one
two and three regions so given the fact
that it's type one i'm now going to
prove this relationship right over here
and then i'll leave it up to you to do
the exact same argument with a type two
and a type 3 region so let's get going
so type 1 region just to remind
ourselves a type 1 region is a so type
type 1 region
type 1 region is a region that is equal
to the set of all x
y's and z's
where or i should say such that
the x y pairs are a member of a domain
in the x y plane and z is bounded by two
functions z's lower bound is f one of x
and y
and that's going to be less than or
equal to z
less than or equal to z and z is upper
bound we can call it f f2
f2
of
f2 of x y and then let me close the set
notation right over here and let me just
draw a general version of a type 1 a
type 1 region so let me draw my x y and
z axes
so this is my
z axis
this is my
x axis
and there is my
y axis and so we might have a region d
we might have a region d here
so our region i'll draw it as a little
circle
a little circle right over here this is
our region d
and for any x y in our region d you can
take you can evaluate the function f you
can figure out an f1 i should say so
this might define an f1 which you can
kind of imagine as a surface or a little
thing that's at the bottom of a cylinder
if you want so this every xy there when
you evaluate or when you figure out what
the corresponding f1 of those points in
this domain would be you might get a
surface that looks something like this
it doesn't have to be flat but hopefully
this gives the idea
it doesn't have to be completely flat it
can be curved or whatever else but this
just shows that every xy when you
evaluate it right over here just so it
gets associated with the point this
lower bound surface right over here and
i'll draw a dotted line to show that's
only for the x y's in this domain and
then we have an upper bound surface
an upper bound surface that might be up
here give me any xy when i evaluate f2 i
get this surface up here
i get this surface up here and once
again they don't have to look the same
this could be like a dome or it could be
slanted or who knows what it might be
but this will give you the general idea
and then z fills up the region remember
the region isn't just the surface of the
figure it's the entire volume inside of
it so when z varies between that surface
and that surface for any given x y in
our domain
we fill up
we fill up the entire region so we fill
up
we and fill up this entire region and so
we and this is the way i drew it looks
like a cylinder but it doesn't have to
be a cylinder like this and this these
two surfaces might touch each other in
which case there would be no side of the
cylinder they could be smooth they could
be lumpier than this they might be
inclined in some way but hopefully this
gives this is a good generalization of a
type 1 region now a type 1 region you
can kind of think of it it can be broken
up into three parts
it can be broken up into
surface or the surfaces of a type 1
region i should say can be broken up
into three parts it can be broken up
into
it can be broken up into let's call that
surface one
surface one let's call this
right over here surface two the top of
the cylinder or whatever kind of lumpy
top it might be and let's call the side
if these two surfaces don't touch each
other let's call that surface 3. there
might not necessarily even be a surface
3 if these two touch each other in the
case of the sphere but let's just assume
that there actually is a surface three
so if we're evaluating the surface
integral we'll think about this double
integral in this or this triple integral
in a second but let's think about how we
can rewrite this surface integral right
over here instead of this entire surface
is s1 plus s2 plus s3 so we can
essentially break this up into three
separate surface integrals so let's do
that so remember we're just focusing on
this part right over here so the surface
integral the surface integral of r
times k
dot n the dot product of k and n
d s can be rewritten as
the
let me write it this way can be rewrit
can be rewritten as
the surface integral over s2 of r
times k
dot n
ds
plus
the surface integral
plus the surface i'm just breaking up
the surface here plus the surface
integral over s1 of r
times k
k
dot n
ds plus
the surface integral over surface 3 of
the same thing r times k
dot n
d s now the way i've drawn this is
actually the case s three is if those
surfaces don't touch each other and for
a type one
situation right over here the normal
vector at any given point on this kind
of the side of the cylinder for this
type one region if there is this in
between region there are always isn't in
the sphere there wouldn't be the surface
in which case this would be zero but if
there is this surface in a type one
region the one that essentially connects
the boundaries of the top and the bottom
then the normal vector will never have a
k component the normal vector will
always be pointing flat out it will only
have an i and j component so if you take
the this normal vector right over here
does not have a k component and you are
dotting it with a k vector then the dot
product of two things that are
orthogonal the k vector goes like that
you're going to get zero so this thing
is going to be this thing is going to be
zero because k dot n is going to be zero
in this situation for the surface k
dot n
is going to be equal to zero
so this part right over here this part
right over here simplifies to this right
over here
now in the next video what we can do is
essentially re-express these in terms of
surface integrals but in in terms of
double integrals over this domain right
over here we'll kind of evaluate these
surface integrals